chez les longues et la pâtisserie c'est
une affaire familiale depuis quatre
générations le savoir-faire se transmet
de père en fils c'est mon arrière grand
père qui a commencé en 1888 il était
pâtissier il a ouvert sa première
boutique en 1906 à vincennes et mon
grand-père a continué en 1946 sur
versailles à l'après guerre et mon père
et mon oncle alain et michel ont repris
en 1973 sur versailles et sont venus au
père en yvelines à côté de rambouillet
sur un site plus approprié pour la
production et on est passé de 1946 à
milhas tojours à 200 mille actuellement
200 milles gâteau sans colorant ni ville
de perm commercialisée pour la grande
distribution en ile de france avec une
particularité ils sont labellisés
saveurs ile de france
donc on peut on fait travailler
effectivement des partenaires locaux
pour une question éthique
et puis c'est beaucoup plus sain
effectivement que de faire venir des
produits de loin pour éviter une du
carbone dans l'environnement un produit
coqueluche pour cette entreprise
familiale de 19 personnes
synonyme d'enfance et de tradition la
madeleine reste encore le produit phare
et surtout actuellement elle revient
redevient un petit peu tendance et
elle reste tendance après sinon bien sûr
nous avons des rochers coco nous avons
des financiers amende qui aurait acquis
plaît bien des moelleux chocolat voilà
mais la madeleine reste le produit phare
qu'on produit le plus les matières
premières de ces petites douceurs son
local mais ce n'est pas tout autres
critères pour obtenir le label saveurs
ile de france
la fabrique ce fait elle aussi juste
derrière la boutique ouverte du lundi au
vendredi de 14 heures à 18 heures